Olá você sabia que um pequeno coágulo
pode mudar a sua vida Em Um Piscar de
Olhos a trombose é uma ameaça silenciosa
que afeta milhares de pessoas todos os
dias mas e se houvesse uma maneira
natural de se proteger hoje eu iniciei
uma série de vídeos que pode transformar
a sua vida e de quem você ama são
histórias reais de pessoas que se
beneficiaram tremendamente com
suplemento natural incrível chamado
picnogenol a apenas os nomes serão
trocados para preservar as suas
identidades e esse é o primeiro Capítulo
de uma jornada que você não vai querer
perder esse vídeo pode mudar tudo na sua
vida Só preciso avisar primeiro que eu
vou usar algumas imagens geradas por
inteligência artificial para ilustrar
esse vídeo já Coloque aqui nos
comentários se você gostou das imagens
geradas por ia para ilustrar ou se você
preferiria que eu utilizasse imagens de
gravações de banco de dados de bancos de
fotos bem Esta é a história do Carlos um
homem de 50 anos pai de família
trabalhador dedicado sempre ativo ele
nunca imaginou que poderia ser vítima de
uma trombose bem depois de uma longa
viagem de avião a trabalho Carlos
Começou a sentir fortes dores na perna
ele foi diagnosticado com trombose
venosa profunda e a sua vida virou de
cabeça para baixo a trombose ocorre
quando um coágulo sanguíneo se se forma
em uma veia ou artéria bloqueando o
fluxo de sangue pode levar a várias
complicações algumas graves como embolia
pulmonar ou até mesmo avc ou chamado
derrame o AVC isquêmico fatores como
sedentarismo viagens prolongadas
predisposição genética todos esses
pontos aumenta o risco Mas por que o
nosso corpo então forma esses coágulos
perigosos os coágulos sanguíneos são uma
resposta fisiológica natural do
organismo para controlar sangramentos e
hemorragias quando ocorre uma lesão
vascular as plaquetas são ativadas
mudando sua forma e aderindo à parede do
vaso danificado para formar um tampão
Inicial embora a coagulação seja um
mecanismo protetor ela pode se tornar
problemática quando ocorre de forma
excessiva ou em locais inadequados
Carlos teve que ser
hospitalizado iniciar um tratamento com
heparina de baixo peso molecular então
trata-se de injeções debaixo da pele ou
subcutâneas que ele teve que fazer por
várias semanas em seguida ele fez um
tratamento com anticoagulante por via
oral que se chama
rivaroxabana graças a Deus tratamento
foi muito bem sucedido e o trombo
retrocedeu Coloque aqui nos comentários
se você conhece alguém que já teve
trombose e Qual medicamento essa pessoa
usou durante o tratamento Estou ansioso
para ler os seus comentários depois da
internação ele procurou um médico
cirurgião vascular e após ter feito um
exame genético descobriu que tinha
mutação no G mthfr que o tornava mais
suscetível mais vulnerável à trombose
assim ele tinha um risco considerável de
ter novos episódios a partir daí o medo
de um novo episódio o amendrontar o
aterrorizava diariamente e ele pensava o
que fazer ficar tomando medicamento o
resto da vida com potenciais efeitos
colaterais sérios então Carlos sabia que
os medicamentos salvaram sua vida mas
ele tinha lido a bula e sabia que o uso
constante deles Poderia gerar problemas
ainda maiores adiante então em busca de
respostas e soluções Carlos descobriu o
picnogenol que é um extrato natural da
casca do Pinheiro marítimo francês Ele
percebeu que o picnogenol era muito bem
tolerado pela maioria das pessoas quando
usado nas doses recomendadas bem ele é
conhecido por suas propriedades
antitrombóticas e o picnogenol surgiu
como uma esperança na prevenção de novos
episódios vamos trocar uma ideia aqui me
avise se você conhece o picnogenol se
você já usou e qual a sua opinião sobre
ele escreve aqui nos comentários bem mas
Como picnogenol atua no nosso organismo
Ele é um poderoso antioxidante que inibe
a agregação plaquetária ou seja ele
impede que as plaquetas se acumul em
forme coágulos Além disso picnogenol ele
tem a capacidade de fortalecer as
paredes dos capilares das veias
prevenindo o vazamento de sangue para os
tecidos e reduzindo o risco de formação
de coágulos ele tem muitas propriedades
fantásticas por exemplo antiinflamatório
que ajudam a proteger o vaso e prevenir
condições que poderiam levar à trombose
então picnogenol reduz o inchaço nas
pernas e pés especialmente durante
viagens longas o que está associado a um
risco menor de trombose teve um estudo
interessante com passageiros de voos de
longa distância e nesse estudo foi
demonstrado que o picnogenol foi eficaz
na prevenção de trombos de trombose
venosa profunda e também de trombose
venosa superficial no grupo que tomou
piquin genol não houve caso de trombose
enquanto no grupo controle que não tomou
nada ocorreram cinco eventos trombóticos
pesquisas indicam que o picnogenol pode
reduzir signif ativamente o risco de
síndrome pós-trombótica e de trombose
venosa profunda que se repete ou seja
trombose venosa profunda recorrente em
comparação com outros tratamentos então
após começar a suplementação com
picnogenol Carlos notou mudanças
significativas a circulação de suas
pernas melhorou o inchaço sumiu ele
estava mais ágil se sentia mais disposto
e o medo constante de novos coágulos deu
lugar Uma tranquilidade não só preveniu
novos dos episódios de trombose mas
também melhorou a sua saúde
cardiovascular como um todo Então
pessoal histórias como de Carlos mostram
como é que essa solução natural pode
transformar vidas bem se a história de
Carlos tocou seu coração não Ignore esse
momento esse pode ser o primeiro passo
para uma vida mais saudável e feliz
informe-se sobre picnogenol converse com
profissionais de saúde e se você gosta
de conteúdo mais aprofundado ou se você
é da área de saúde e quis aprender mais
sobre picnogenol assista a aula completa
que eu vou colocar no meu outro canal o
link vai estar aqui na descrição e no
primeiro comentário e não perca os
próximos vídeos dessa série eles podem
ser a chave para transformar sua vida e
a de seus entes queridos juntos Podemos
construir um futuro melhor Foi muito bom
falar com você Ah e é muito importante a
sua opinião me diga se você gostou desse
formato de informações em saúde falando
de casos reais ou se você prefere um
vídeo que seja mais direto mais
científico só focando apenas nas
características de um produto de saúde e
em como tratar doenças em geral sem essa
parte de eu dar exemplos ou ilustrações
de casos compar os vídeos bem a de
algém
[Música]
tamb um grande abraço
você é fera um beijo no seu coração